hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm Tara Erickson Erickson is here
guys I am so excited that you're back
because I want to tell you guys that
Tara Erickson has put together a comedy
placed and it's a whole kind of mixture
of things that sold out opening night
and I'm gonna be going there opening
night got my tickets as well you guys
should come say hi it's called Alexa
turn off heartbreak she's gonna be doing
a few shows over at Studio C on Santa
Monica Boulevard so if you guys are in
the LA area or are willing to make a
drive down here please go check it out
I'm gonna go opening night come say hi
there's a link in the description box of
the Facebook events that way you guys
can go check it out her and her friend
Sasha they wrote it they put it together
they're starring in it I cannot wait to
check it out I'm so proud of you for
playing yeah I wanted her to come back
so I could tell you guys all about it
also you guys can enter the code real
rejects if you guys want five dollars
off a ticket when you go for real real
rejects enter that code and the discount
code you get five dollars off a ticket
come to any of the four dates in June
come say hi say you family through
rejects or just come say hi whatever
it's gonna be starting I display about
dating in LA and breakups and it's funny
we want you to laugh but we also want
you to feel Tara you've seen Deadpool 1
uh-huh sure half we're gonna watch two
things for Deadpool two we're gonna
watch this little promo big called
beating Avengers and then we're gonna
watch a movie clip they released ok
are you excited to check it out I love
it let's give me some Ryan the new
uniforms
guys this is insane
[Music]
what in Pogba they're not wearing the
official Deadpool kneepads I know they
don't wear kneepads but they sure do now
[Music]
when you do sequel you got to double
down on the promos otherwise you get
beaten by infinity oh my god it's so
good oh gosh they just keep amping up
the marketing on what they're doing here
her death will - I mean I'm not even a
soccer fan at all me neither but that
was like clever promo that's a clever
player also Ryan Reynolds voice I love
this voice it's not even like deep and
you're gonna double down on the promos
that's not it well let's move on to the
movie clip now though so this movie clip
is called
fire fist vs. x-men now fire fist fire
faces might be the kid yeah okay let's
see
he's the x-men or arriving my job you're
the one who said I was ready and I
frankly disagree but here we are
please look in the real under control it
is I'll ask the questions let me talk to
the kid you stay here with your weird
secret sex lips yeah probably shoulda
brought a SuperSoaker
hi there okay cool
Justin Bieber thighs [ __ ] that's the
beaver he called you Justin Bieber
whatever that is okay let's just talk
rates Russell right boy first
that's a great name
where does it burn just the fist or all
the way up to the elbow
all the way to the elbow come quietly or
there it will be trouble
[Music]
[Music]
literally a movie based solely on its
promo trailers until right now right
that's cool Devils of embracing a heroic
side in this one around because I know
in the last one the big thing was he's
not a hero then he's just trying to save
his girlfriend he's a girl from back and
get his revenge yeah and this one he's
actively going out there trying to save
the world I wonder how that's gonna feel
this time around it seems like they're
finding the right blend of doing that I
agree so that he's not too much x-men
and like Super Saver that he's still a
little bit of that undergrad like dead
yeah that like edgy nice to him where
he's still an antihero in a way he's not
just embracing it like you said the
savior aspect to it though he's trying
to save this kid he's getting the other
two injured like I'm doing my job which
I told you it was ready for but you told
me I was so now I'm here and I'm like I
love that line yo God that is so good
for Beyonce you know you just look at
her and you go watch heat on her nobody
knows you have to be an insane person
well Beyonce's career she hadn't that
awesome HBO thing after she got cheated
on so she made a lot I mean making
lemonade out of lemons Wow
I don't think I had enough coffee this
morning toughy I also like the way the
scene played out though a lot of times
they release these movie clips online
that seemed ridiculously shorter chopped
up weird this is a different director
and I was kind of concerned that he
wouldn't understand the comedic timing
to this because right movies are like
John wick oh okay blonde interest so go
do like something that's so known for
its comedy and like I knew he would do
the action but right very obviously he
can handle the comedy very well because
this seemed played out great didn't seem
weird at all the comedy didn't seem
forced I'm like no this is a vintage
Deadpool right it seems like you really
nailed it hashtag not a comedy trainee
next did the director's name see what I
did there I gave him a hashtag based off
your stuff while you said
Adam just now nowhere else hate for you
again I see the stress in your face
hashtag not a comedy training anymore
maybe I'll add anymore at the end I know
you think action ash and kick kick kick
like John wick and Thomas blonde but I
got the comedy handled too so here's one
more hashtag just real quick
hashtag comedy handler you're welcome
what's his name those are gonna be
improv at your show yep lots of okay
every word is written Gregory okay I've
gotten 60 pages to memorize wow that's a
lot I think we're safe then you guys
should still go check out Alexa turn off
heartbreak yeah make sure to get your
tickets checker Unni anyway you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bail because subscribe
buttons don't work
check out Tara Erikson's channel where
she does reactions and trailer
reenactments actually it's some really
funny [ __ ] it's her Avengers 1 that's it
maybe check it out thank you so much
promo may 31st but no you're gonna come
in June because we're a sold-out